so one day they bring him his food and
he had that strained voice you know that
you know and he goes I said I wanted
tilapia and this is like and day six uh
he's a druggie who's been um shooting
into his foot and now it's so infected
that they're telling him if this deluded
is not helping you we are going to have
to take your foot oo and the last stage
I wonder if you could bring this up
they're talking to him about maggot
therapy and I guess they put maggots on
the dead skin and like this is the this
is the last step before we take your fo
off that's what they're doing there's a
foot right there that's what they're
that's what he probably had over there
he's eating tilapia with that
foot he's more worried about fish than
that foot